[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHEN SMITH: So
what time is it?
It's early on Easter
Sunday morning.
We remember that "Inferno"
started on Good Friday
morning and then proceeded
through Friday night and Holy
Saturday.
What rest there was, was the
kind of rest you get in hell.
Maybe as the old saying
goes, a bad night
in a bad motel,
something like that.
When Dante and Virgil
emerge now at the beginning
of "Purgatorio" it
is into this new day
and to this moment near
dawn on Easter Sunday.
It's interesting to
think, by the way,
of the "Inferno" as a
journey that takes place
across Holy Saturday.
Students, of course,
love to point out
that Dante's quest
resembles one of their more
frequent, and
frequently lamented,
practices, the all-nighter.
So when Dante and Virgil
emerge, it's after that journey
and now finally on the
shores of Purgatorio.
Let's jump in to Canto 1 and
notice a few things together.
"I will sing about that second
realm given the human soul
to purge its sin and grow
worthy to climb to paradise.
Here rise to life
again dead poetry."
It's a beautiful,
striking opening.
So probably the most
interesting line
is that last one, though,
"Here rise to life
again dead poetry."
And I wish someone had
told me at least a little
bit earlier that we were
reading dead poetry.
But we learn about it now--
or so it seems.
It's not entirely clear
what that line means.
At a minimum, here on
Easter Sunday morning,
poetry itself is going
to rise to new life.
No more poetry of death,
no more poetry of despair,
no more poetry of the lost.
While the poem is
certainly about the state
of souls after death and
these three parts of eternity,
it's also about
the present moment.
It's about the here and now.
And so one of the great
fruits of the poem
is to help us, the readers,
in the present moment
of our lives, in our present
duties in the here and now.
One of the things
Dante does better
than anyone is to help give the
reader a perspective on life
that's reliable and
trustworthy and helpful.
It's very easy to lose
perspective in life.
It's very easy to have
a skewed perspective.
And what Dante does is he
gives us an eternal perspective
on the soul, on freedom,
on love, on God,
and that's one of the greatest
gifts any teacher could
give to a student,
any poet to a reader,
any artist to an audience.
The beginning of
Dante's "Purgatorio."